وزير الامن المكسيكي السابق معتقل في
امريكا بواجه القضاء فيها في محاكمه لها
بادئه شهر ومداولتها استمرت ايام واليوم
اصدرت هيئه المحلفين قرارهم وادانه في
خمستهم حقيقه قضيه هذا الوزير ممكن
نعاونها حاميها حراميها فاللي كان وزير
الامن وبيقود حرب المكسيك على المخدرات
وتهريبها لامريكا ودين بتهم الفساد وتهريب
المخدرات ومنها تلقي ملايين الدولارات
لحمايه اكبر عصابه لتهريب المخدرات في
البلاد اللي هي كارتل سينالوا هذه اللي
كان رئيسها يعني طبعا شخصيه معروفه جدا في
عالم الاجرام والمخدرات ومشاركه في
الاتجار ب 53 طن من الكوكايين من المكسيك
لامريكا القضيه اثبتت بالادله وبعد
الاستماع لشهود منهم اعضاء معتقلين من
الكرتل واتضح انه الوزير السابق كان بياخذ
فلوس من العصابات مقابل تسهيل عملهم
وتهريب المخدرات بشكل امن وكان يبلغهم
باماكن تواجد الدوريات هذا الوزير السابق
الان وبعد ازالته بيواجه حكم ممكن يوصل
للسجن مدى الحياه والحكم منتظر انه يصدر
في 27 يونيو ويبدو انه كثير ناس يعني
منتظرين محاكمته والحكم عليه لانهم كانوا
متواجدين خارج المحكمه وجالسين حتى
بيطالبوا بمحاسبته وبيتابعوا المحاكمه
بشكل دقيق وعلى فكره المجرمه المدان ما
كان بس وزير الامن السابق لكنه كان ايضا
يوما مع شرطي ومن ثم رئيس وكاله
الاستخبارات لمكافحه الفساد والجريمه
المنظمه يعني يعتبر اكبر مسؤول مكسيكي
بيتحكم في القضاء الامريكي في حرب ضد
عصابات تهريب المخدرات في امريكا الوسطى
والجنوبيه واللي بتستغل تواطئ وزراء
محليين عشان تغرق امريكا الشماليه
بالمخدرات
[موسيقى]